المترجم: Imane Elaouam
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
السلام عليكم
هل يوجد شخص لا يحمل هاتف ذكي الآن؟
هل تعرفون لماذا سموه هاتف ذكي؟
لأن نظام التشغيل يدعم تطبيقات كثيرة
لم يعد يقدم خدمات إرسال واستقبال فقط
لا بل أصبح يدعم تطبيق:
تستطيع أن ترسل رسائل
تستطيع أن تتصفح الإنترنت
تستطيع أن تحمل الأفلام
أغاني وألعاب وصور وأشياء كثيرة
بالنسبة لي،
أصبحت 60٪ من قدرات
عقلك تتحولت إلى هذا الجهاز
في العام 2007،
صعد ستيف جوبز إلى المنصة
وشرح مميزات جهاز الأيفون 3G.
في تلك الأيام الأيفون 3G أحدث ضجة.
عندما ظهر 3G،
قال: "سأحدث ثورة وسأصنع تاريخًا"
في ذلك الوقت،
و فعلا أحدث ثورة وصنع تاريخًا.
في تلك الأيام كنت
أتذكر أرقام هاتف أبي وأمي
أما الآن فلا أتذكرهم،
حتى زوجتي أنسى رقمها.
طبعا في 2011،
اشتريت أول أيفون وهو سيري
أول أيفون S4
اشتريته بسبب خدمة سيري.
في تلك الأيام أحدث ضجة
و قلت في نفسي كيف يعمل هذا البرنامج
و قلت هو عبارة عن دليل
ذكي يحول الصوت إلى ديجيتال،
وبعد ذلك يضعها في قاعدة بيانات،
وبعد ذلك يبحث عن المعلومة،
بهذه البساطة.
الذكاء الصناعي يحتاج قاعدة
بيانات ضخمة فيها معلومات كبيرة
وتجهيز عالي.
عندما تتصفح أنت بالفيسبوك أو الإنستجرام،
في الفايسبوك فجأة تجد...
تجد جوابًا.
تظهر لك صور أصحابك من أيام الدراسة
بعد ذلك عندما تتصفح اليوتيوب،
بعد ذلك تظهر المقاطع المفضلة
كيف ظهرت هذه المقاطع؟
كيف عرف الفايسبوك هذا ؟
هناك شيء اسمه التنقيب عن البيانات.
هذه أداة تبحث عن المعلومة
في قاعدة البيانات.
في العام 2012،
شركات كبيرة صارت تشتكي
من أحجام المعلومات الكبيرة التي تحدث
بسبب تراكم المعلومات في الإستخدام.
فالشركات بعضها عندها الحل:
إما بأن تمحي البيانات الموجودة،
وإما أن تضعها في نسخ احتياطية
أو تضعها في خدمات سحابية.
في 2013، ظهر شيء اسمه البيانات الضخمة.
حل هذه المشكلة،
هي قاعدة بيانات ذكية،
عالية السرعة وعالية الدقة
في تحليل المعلومة.
هذه ساعدت بشكل كبير
في تطوير الذكاء الصناعي بالمعرفة،
فأصبح يزداد إنتاجه وتقل نسبة أخطائه،
تصل في بعض الأحيان %0
فيسبوك في 2014،
فيسبوك اشترى واتساب
اشتراه بمبلغ 19 مليار دولار.
بسبب ماذا؟
هو تطبيق كلنا نستخدمه.
ولكن عنده قاعدة بيانات صحيحة،
لأنه مربوط برقم الجوال.
فصحيحة.
لهذا دفع هذا المبلغ.
وهو آخر تصريح من مؤسس فايسبوك قال:
"يستخدم نظام الذكاء الصناعي
في تطوير الرسائل الفورية في الواتساب"
جوجل وهي عبارة عن محرك البحث،
يأخد المعلومة ويرسلها للطرف التاني،
لكن الآن أصبح مجاله أكبر
أصبحت لديه قاعدة بيانات كبيرة،
يستطيع استخدامها في أشياء كثيرة.
فاشترى شركة اسمها "ديب مايند"
هذه شركة متخصصة في مجال الذكاء الصناعي.
بعدها جوجل بدأ يضع تطبيقات ذكية،
مثل استخدام جوجل ماب
والبرمجة وأشياء كثيرة.
طبعا عصر التواصل انتهى.
في الفترة القادمة سيكون عصر "السمارت"
هناك "سمارت هاوس" و"سمارت كارت"،
هناك أشياء كثيرة.
كما يمكن أن تجد مستقبلا "سمارت وايف"
أشياء كثيرة في المستقبل.
في العام 2030،
طبعا الذكاء الصناعي سيستخدم جميع الوظائف،
قد تصل إلى 60٪ من الوظائف التي نستخدمها
أكبر تهديد للذكاء الصناعي.
وهذا "ستيفن هوكينغ" عالم في الفيزياء،
ويعلم ماذا يقول
في 2030، يقول في الإحصائيات،
60٪ من الوظائف التي نستخدمها ستلغى.
ستصبح هناك أنظمة ذكية،
التي ستبدأ بحل كل مشاكلها بنفسها.
تبدأ تأخد قراراتها بنفسها.
فسيصبح تهديد.
فالوظائف الإبداعية
هي التي ستصمد في 2030.
فلنعمل سويا لتعليم أجيالنا
مهارات التفكير والإبداع،
ونشجعهم على الإختراع.
بمساندة التقنية وليس الاعتماد عليها.
شكرًا جزيلًا لكم
(تصفيق)